From PRI, Public Radio International. From PRI, Public Radio International. From PRI, Public Radio  International. Public Radio. Public Radio International.
来自PRI，公共广播国际。来自PRI，公共广播国际。来自PRI，公共广播国际。公共广播。公共广播国际。
So when I heard that a woman named Samantha Martin had trained raccoons to play basketball and hires them out for parties and corporate events, I pictured raccoons in three-on-three or four-on-four games in little Chicago Bulls uniforms. Raccoon Scottie Pippen passes to raccoon Dennis Rodman. Raccoon Michael Jordan, you know, takes it in for a lay up or dunks it. The other team is a little raccoon Orlando Magic or Los Angeles Lakers. I could see it all. But that is not what it was like. No, no, no. That was naive.
所以当我听说一个叫萨曼莎·马丁的女人训练浣熊打篮球，并把它们租给派对和公司活动时，我想象的是浣熊穿着小小的芝加哥公牛队队服，打三对三或四对四的比赛。浣熊斯科蒂·皮蓬传球给浣熊丹尼斯·罗德曼。浣熊迈克尔·乔丹，你知道的，带球上篮或者扣篮。对方球队是小浣熊奥兰多魔术队或洛杉矶湖人队。我完全能想象出那个画面。但这根本不是那样的。不，不，不。那太天真了。
Ricky. Come here, Ricky. Ricky. Ricky. Snacks? Here you go. Shoot. Ricky, shoot. C'mon, Ricky. Ricky, come here.
里奇。过来，里奇。里奇。里奇。吃零食吗？给你。投篮。里奇，投篮。来吧，里奇。里奇，过来。
Samantha Martin chases after one of her two basketball-playing raccoons, holding a bag of blue and pink cotton candy. She alternates, actually between taking a fingerful of cotton candy for herself and giving one to the raccoon.
萨曼莎·马丁追着她两只打篮球的浣熊中的一只，手里拿着一袋蓝色和粉色的棉花糖。实际上，她在一边自己吃一撮棉花糖，一边给浣熊喂一撮之间交替着。
Yummy sugar. Shoot, Ricky. You don't want the snacks?
美味的糖。投篮，里奇。你不想要零食吗？
Samantha's actually a skilled and successful trainer, but the animals are not cooperating this day, probably because Samantha went away for the holidays and they're still feeling neglected. Samantha puts a grapefruit-sized ball in the raccoon's hand and then pushes the raccoon's hand toward a Fisher-Price basketball net that rises perhaps a foot and a half off the floor.
萨曼莎其实是一位技术娴熟且成功的训练师，但动物们今天不太配合，可能是因为萨曼莎去度假了，它们觉得被冷落了。萨曼莎把一个葡萄大小的球放在浣熊手里，然后推着浣熊的手朝一个离地大约一英尺半的费雪牌篮球架投去。
Ah, you missed. Shoot again. Shoot. Good girl.
啊，你投偏了。再投一次。投篮。好姑娘。
The fact is, there are things that raccoons like to do, are born to do. Playing basketball is not one of them.
事实是，有些事情是浣熊喜欢做的，天生就会做的。打篮球不在此列。
Oh, I know. it's frustrating. You have to have a lot of patience. Especially when I was first training them to play basketball, you know how long it took me? It took me a month to get them to play basketball. Every day, I had to come down here and play with ball, net, ball, net, treat. And you just see going through their mind, OK, ball. They touch the ball, then they touch the net and they'd get a treat. They'd be like, ball, net, treat! Treat!
哦，我知道。这很令人沮丧。你必须非常有耐心。特别是我刚开始训练它们打篮球的时候，你知道我花了多久吗？我花了一个月才教会它们打篮球。每天，我都得来这儿，玩球、篮筐、球、篮筐、零食。你就能看着它们脑子里在想，噢，球。它们碰一下球，然后碰一下篮筐，就能得到零食。它们就会想：球，篮筐，零食！零食！
And then I started getting them to hold the ball. And then I got them to push the ball into the net. And finally, that day came where they picked up the ball off the ground and popped it in the net. And I was so thrilled. I was like, "Oh, they got it." And he got all excited, and he just kept picking up the ball and putting it in the net, picking up the ball and putting it in the net, over and over again. He got so excited.
然后我开始让它们拿住球。接着我让它们把球推到篮筐里。最后，那一天终于来了，它们从地上捡起球，把它投进篮筐。我当时太激动了。我就想：“哦，它们学会了。”它也变得非常兴奋，不停地捡起球放进篮筐，捡起球放进篮筐，一遍又一遍。它太兴奋了。
Taming animals means basically teaching them to conform to the human world, teaching them human expectations. And with many of the animals that Samantha raises, it's possible to make them more human while they're little. But then, once they reach a certain age, their real animal nature kicks in. A baby cougar she was raising started stalking her friends, biting at their throats. The raccoons also go for the throat.
驯化动物基本上意味着教它们适应人类的世界，教它们人类的期望。对于萨曼莎养的许多动物，它们小时候是有可能让人类化程度更高一些的。但到了某个年龄，它们真正的动物本性就会显现出来。她养的一只美洲狮幼崽开始跟踪她的朋友，咬它们的喉咙。浣熊也会攻击喉咙。
If he's out of his cage, he'll run up. He'll look at you, and he'll recognize me as mom from years ago. He'll be like, "Mom!" And he'll race up to me, jump up, climb up to my shoulder, and realize, "Wait, I'm wild. I don't like you anymore." And he'll bite my neck.
如果它从笼子里出来，它会跑过来。它会看着你，认出我就是多年前的妈妈。它会像在说：“妈妈！”然后它会冲向我，跳起来，爬到我的肩膀上，然后意识到：“等等，我是野生的。我不再喜欢你了。”然后它会咬我的脖子。
You see it inside. Their eyes go from crazy to tame, crazy to tame. Crazy, crazy, tame, tame. It's almost like they're saying, "No, mom, love you. Must bite! Must bite! No, no, nice. Mom nice. Oh, yes, we love mom. Bite! Must bite! Must bite! No! No!" They just fight it. You just see this battle going on in their heads. They're like, [MAKING ANIMAL NOISES]
你可以看到它们内心的挣扎。它们的眼神从疯狂到温顺，从疯狂到温顺。疯狂，疯狂，温顺，温顺。就像它们在说：“不，妈妈，爱你。必须咬！必须咬！不，不，乖。妈妈乖。哦，是的，我们爱妈妈。咬！必须咬！必须咬！不！不！”它们只是在抗拒。你可以看到它们脑子里正在进行的这场战斗。它们就像是，[发出动物的声音]
What do we want from animals? To run her business, Samantha has had to figure this out. And at parties or corporate events, in commercials and films, Samantha has her raccoons pick pockets and play basketball. She has rats that bowl, rats that answer toy telephones.
我们想要动物做什么？为了经营她的事业，萨曼莎不得不弄清楚这一点。在派对或公司活动上，在商业广告和电影中，萨曼莎让她的浣熊偷钱包和打篮球。她还有会打保龄球的老鼠，会接听玩具电话的老鼠。
Do people want to see animals do animal things?
人们想看动物做动物做的事吗？
No, they don't. They want to see animals acting like people.
不，他们不想。他们想看动物表现得像人一样。
Most of us, the only animals we ever see are animals who act like humans. You know, cats and dogs. We watch movies and TV shows and commercials that are filled with animals that fetch beers from the refrigerator and solve crimes. And we forget the sheer animal-ness of animals. We don't see it. Maybe we don't want to see it.
我们大多数人，唯一见过的动物就是表现得像人类的动物。你知道，猫和狗。我们看电影、电视节目和广告，里面充满了会从冰箱里拿啤酒和破案的动物。我们忘记了动物纯粹的“动物性”。我们看不见它。也许我们不想看见它。
Well, this brings us to the topic of today's program. From WBEZ, of course, it's This American Life . I'm Ira Glass. Today on our program, The Animal-ness of Animals. Our show today in three acts.
好吧，这带出了今天节目的主题。当然，来自WBEZ的《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。今天我们的节目主题是“动物的动物性”。我们今天的节目分为三幕。
Act One, Staging the Food Chain in a New York Apartment. Act Two, Animal Court. That's an original radio play by David Sedaris. Act Three, The Moment Humans Stopped Being Animals That's a story by Scott Carrier. Stay with us.
第一幕，在纽约公寓里上演食物链。第二幕，动物法庭。那是大卫·塞达里斯创作的一部原创广播剧。第三幕，人类不再是动物的那一刻，那是斯科特·卡里尔写的一个故事。请继续收听。
Act One. Usually when we see pictures of animals, they're fluffy and cute or they're noble and dignified. Well, compare that to this set of photos by Catherine Chalmers. In this first picture, we have a caterpillar eating a tomato-- a brightly-colored close-up of that. The second picture, a praying mantis eats the caterpillar. And in the third picture, a tarantula eats the praying mantis. Catherine Chalmers takes these pictures in her own apartment in New York City where she also raises the animals that she feeds to each other. Paul Tough stopped by for a visit.
第一幕。通常我们看到动物的照片时，它们都是毛茸茸的、可爱的，或者是高贵且庄严的。好吧，对比一下凯瑟琳·查尔莫斯拍的这组照片。在第一张照片里，我们有一只正在吃番茄的毛毛虫——那是色彩鲜艳的特写。第二张照片，一只螳螂吃掉了毛毛虫。第三张照片，一只狼蛛吃掉了螳螂。凯瑟琳·查尔莫斯在纽约市她自己的公寓里拍摄这些照片，她也在那里饲养她互相喂食的动物。保罗·托夫去拜访了一下。
Growing up, Catherine Chalmers wasn't really an animal person. She always had a pet or two, nothing unusual. But then a few years ago, she was working on these sculptures, where she would take dead insects and glue them onto plants and flowers. She needed a lot of dead flies. More than she could buy anywhere.
在成长过程中，凯瑟琳·查尔莫斯并不是一个特别喜欢动物的人。她总是养一两只宠物，没什么特别的。但几年前，她在做雕塑，要把死昆虫粘在植物和花朵上。她需要很多死苍蝇。比她能在任何地方买到的都要多。
And so she decided to start raising live flies in a glass cage in the corner of her apartment. She would just let them breed and wait for them to die. But then one day, she picked up a camera and looked at the flies through a close-up lens.
于是她决定开始在公寓角落的一个玻璃笼子里养活苍蝇。她只是让它们繁殖，等着它们死去。但有一天，她拿起相机，透过微距镜头观察这些苍蝇。
And the world changed, because instead of just seeing patterns of swarming flies, I saw leg hairs and genitals and mouths. I saw them, I saw their lives, how they would kind of greet each other and what they would do. And I could see them being born, I could see them having sex, I could see them eating, I could see them flying, I could see them hanging out. And it was great. It was fascinating. So I'd sit there for hours, or until they went to the bathroom on the glass enough I couldn't see anymore. And that's when I kind of got hooked into animals past a certain point of return.
世界改变了，因为我看到的不再仅仅是成群结队的苍蝇，我看到了腿毛、生殖器和嘴巴。我看到了它们，看到了它们的生活，它们是如何互相打招呼以及它们会做些什么。我能看到它们出生，看到它们交配，看到它们进食，看到它们飞翔，看到它们闲逛。这太棒了。这太迷人了。所以我会在那儿坐上几个小时，或者直到它们在玻璃上排泄到我看不到为止。就在那时，我进入了一个无法回头的动物世界。
She realized that there were two basic moments of life that she couldn't see in the flies' cage. She couldn't see them eating, and she couldn't see them dying. So she came up with this project that she called The Food Chain. She decided to raise a few different animals-- caterpillars, praying mantises, frogs, spiders-- and take pictures of each animal eating the one that came beneath it in the natural food chain.
她意识到在苍蝇笼里有两个基本的生活时刻她看不到。她看不到它们进食，也看不到它们死亡。所以她想出了这个她称之为“食物链”的项目。她决定饲养几种不同的动物——毛毛虫、螳螂、青蛙、蜘蛛——并拍摄每种动物吃掉自然食物链中位于其下一级的动物的照片。
When I first thought of this project, when it first dawned on me, what I was fishing around for, it kind of made my stomach hurt. The idea of raising animals to be eaten-- to photograph them specifically to be eaten-- was repugnant. It made me kind of sick. The more I've thought of it, the more interesting I thought it was.
当我第一次想到这个项目时，当我第一次意识到我在寻找什么时，我的胃部一阵不适。养动物来喂养其他动物——专门为了拍照而让它们被吃掉——这种想法是令人反感的。这让我觉得有点恶心。但我越是思考，就越觉得它很有意思。
So Catherine began to fill her loft with animals. There isn't much furniture, but every surface has got terrariums and cages on it-- frogs and mealworms and a snake on one table; goldfish in the kitchen to feed the frogs; crickets, which chirp constantly; a tarantula and two cages full of mice. On a spare corner of the table where the frogs and the snake live, she's got a light box set up. And we sit down there to take a look at some of her pictures.
于是凯瑟琳开始用动物填满她的阁楼。没多少家具，但每个平面上都放着饲养箱和笼子——一张桌子上放着青蛙、面包虫和蛇；厨房里放着喂青蛙的金鱼；不停鸣叫的蟋蟀；一只狼蛛和两个装满老鼠的笼子。在青蛙和蛇居住的桌子的空角落里，她架设了一个灯箱。我们坐在那儿看了看她的一些照片。
So this is basically the food chain.
所以这基本上就是食物链。
The photos don't look like normal nature photography. They look more like fashion shots. The animals are brightly lit and sharply focused, pictured against a clear, white background.
这些照片看起来不像普通的自然摄影。它们看起来更像是时尚摄影。动物们在清晰的白色背景下，光线明亮，对焦锐利。
It starts with caterpillars that eat tomatoes. Praying mantises eat the caterpillars. And my original idea was for the spider-- tarantula-- to eat the praying mantises. But spiders are really undependable predators--
它始于吃番茄的毛毛虫。螳螂吃毛毛虫。我最初的想法是让蜘蛛——狼蛛——去吃螳螂。但蜘蛛是极其不可靠的捕食者——
If there were two emotions competing in Catherine Chalmers-- her fascination with the food chain and her disgust with what she was doing-- it becomes clear to me as she shows me her work that in the end, her fascination won out. She lays out a sequence of shots that begin with the praying mantis about to attack a caterpillar.
如果凯瑟琳·查尔莫斯内心有两种情绪在较量——她对食物链的迷恋和她对自己所作所为的厌恶——那么当她向我展示她的作品时，我很清楚，最终她的迷恋占了上风。她摆出一系列照片，开始时是螳螂准备攻击毛毛虫。
That's the part  that's really great is she springs on it and she wraps her arms around it. And she just starts biting into it. And the thing's live and it's still kicking. And with the caterpillars, since all they do is eat, basically their body is just one long digestive system. And so whatever they are eating, as soon as she bites into it, it just spills out.
那部分真的很棒，它猛扑过去，用双臂缠住它。然后它就开始咬它。那个东西还活着，还在挣扎。而毛毛虫，因为它们只会吃，基本上它们的身体就是一整条消化系统。所以无论它们在吃什么，当它咬下去的时候，它就直接流出来了。
So if they're eating leaves, when she bites into it-- and this was totally a surprise when this first happened-- it comes out green or it comes out bright red, the color of the tomatoes, or it comes out bright yellow if you're feeding then yellow tomatoes. So I did different sequences of caterpillar with different-colored guts coming out.
所以如果它们在吃叶子，当它咬下去的时候——这在第一次发生时完全是个惊喜——它流出来的就是绿色的，或者流出来的是鲜红色的，那是番茄的颜色，或者如果你喂它们黄色的番茄，流出来的就是鲜黄色的。所以我做了一系列不同颜色的毛毛虫内脏流出来的序列。
And it was just beautiful. I didn't know that an animal eating something live could be so attractive. It was like spilling a tube of paint out on a white piece of canvas. It just blobs out. It's gruesome if you think about it in terms of your brother or your sister, but in terms of the fact that it is an insect and we seem less attached to the insect world than certainly the human world, it was very beautiful.
这真是太美了。我不知道动物吃活物竟然能这么有吸引力。就像把一管颜料洒在白色的画布上。它就这样喷涌而出。如果你把它和你的兄弟姐妹联系起来想，这很可怕，但考虑到它只是一只昆虫，而且我们似乎比人类世界更少地对昆虫世界产生感情，它真的很美。
You'd think it would be easy to take pictures of predators eating their prey. That's what they do, after all. But it turns out to be more complicated than just putting a couple of animals together and snapping away. There are considerations of timing and staging. When she tried to have frogs eat the praying mantises, the problem was the frogs were simply too fast. Photo one would show a hungry frog and a praying mantis, and photo two would just show a well-fed frog.
你会觉得拍摄捕食者吃掉猎物的照片很容易。毕竟，这就是它们做的事。但事实证明，这比把几只动物放在一起然后拍照要复杂得多。这里涉及到时机和舞台布置的考量。当她尝试让青蛙吃螳螂时，问题在于青蛙实在太快了。第一张照片会显示一只饥饿的青蛙和一只螳螂，而第二张照片只会出现一只吃饱了的青蛙。
Then there was the tarantula problem. Tarantulas can go for months without eating and days without moving. She'd put the spider and the praying mantis up on her set, and the tarantula would just stare at the praying mantis, completely still, one leg in the air, for hours. Finally, in one session, at 3:00 in the morning, after staring at her camera all night, Catherine got what she wanted. She slides the photos onto the light box.
然后是狼蛛的问题。狼蛛可以几个月不吃东西，几天不动弹。她把蜘蛛和螳螂放在她的布景上，狼蛛只会盯着螳螂看，完全不动，一条腿悬在空中，一盯就是几个小时。最后，在一次拍摄中，凌晨3点，在盯着她的相机整晚之后，凯瑟琳得到了她想要的。她把照片滑到灯箱上。
You see the shot where the two of them are looking at each other. And then, basically, the spider pounced on it and flipped it over. And the praying mantis is upside down looking straight at you. And perfectly alive, looking at you, as the spider is munching on the middle part of his body. And then you see his head, and its antennas are waving around, and slowly, the head gets drawn more and more into the jaws. And it's still alive.
你看到那张它们互相看着对方的照片。然后，基本上，蜘蛛扑了上去，把它翻了过来。螳螂仰面朝天，直勾勾地盯着你。而且它完全活着，正看着你，而蜘蛛正在啃食它身体的中部。然后你看到它的头，触角在四处挥动，慢慢地，头被一点点拖进了下颚。而且它还活着。
And then, the spider basically mushes it up into a ball and extracts the juices out of it. And it took, maybe, three or four hours for it to eat the whole thing. And for at least half of that time, the praying mantis was perfectly alive. And it was hard, because you'd spent so long raising this thing. It was really hard to see it being eaten alive like that and having it take so long.
然后，蜘蛛基本上把它搅成一团，吸取它的汁液。吃掉整个东西大概花了三四个小时。而且在那段时间里，至少有一半的时间，螳螂是完全活着的。这很难，因为你花了那么长时间来养这个东西。看着它那样被活着吃掉，而且过程如此漫长，真的很难受。
At this point in The Food Chain, her pictures were becoming more and more vivid, but so was the suffering that she was watching through her lens.
在“食物链”项目的这个阶段，她的照片变得越来越生动，但她透过镜头所观察到的苦难也一样。
I got attached to the praying mantises. Seeing the praying mantises die was definitely much harder than seeing the caterpillars dying. Unlike most insects, they have a head that moves like ours does-- on a neck. And so they turn and they look at you. And they've got these big eyes sticking out. And they have some of the characteristics of the things which usually win human sympathy, which is big eyes and kind of an expression. And their mouth is red on the inside, so when they would eat something, it looked like they had red lipstick on. It was much easier to get attached to them.
我对螳螂产生了感情。看着螳螂死去绝对比看着毛毛虫死去要困难得多。不像大多数昆虫，它们有一个像我们一样会转动的头——长在脖子上。所以它们会转过头看着你。它们有突出的那双大眼睛。它们具备一些通常能赢得人类同情的特征，那就是大眼睛和某种表情。它们的嘴巴里面是红色的，所以当它们吃东西时，看起来就像涂了红色唇膏一样。要对它们产生感情要容易得多。
One of the things that The Food Chain photos have made Catherine think about is how we humans choose which channels we love and which ones we hate-- the distinction we make, basically, between pets and pests. She says most of us are attracted to animals that are like us-- that are mammals, that have round faces and big eyes like human infants. And she's not immune to that instinct. Her favorite animal is her dog, Leo.
“食物链”照片让凯瑟琳思考的一件事是，我们人类是如何选择我们所爱和我们所恨的渠道的——基本上就是我们在宠物和害虫之间作出的区分。她说我们大多数人被那些像我们的动物所吸引——也就是哺乳动物，拥有像人类婴儿那样圆圆的脸和大大的眼睛。她也无法抗拒这种本能。她最喜欢的动物是她的狗，里奥。
But she also finds herself drawn to the animals the we are supposed to fear and the moments in their lives that we usually turn away from. At the light box, she puts down four new photos from a different project, a series of shots of two praying mantises having sex.
但她也发现自己被我们本应恐惧的动物所吸引，被它们生命中我们通常会回避的时刻所吸引。在灯箱旁，她放下了四个来自另一个项目的新照片，这是一系列两只螳螂正在交配的照片。
So that's the female, that's the male. She's a lot bigger. Then they mated. Look like a nice, happy couple. He has green eyes, she has brown.
这是雌性，这是雄性。她大得多。然后它们交配了。看起来像一对美好、快乐的伴侣。他有绿眼睛，她有棕色眼睛。
So he's on top of her.
所以他在她身上。
He's on top of her, and it's just like classic doggy-style sex position. And they stay that way for hours-- hours and hours and hours. I'll take a few pictures, I'll come back in 20 minutes, take a few more pictures, come back in 20 minutes.
他在她身上，就像典型的男上女下的性交姿势。它们就这样待了好几个小时——几个小时又几个小时又几个小时。我会拍几张照片，20分钟后再回来，再拍几张，20分钟后再回来。
Isn't that kind of rare for animals? I thought animals were sort of-- do it quick.
那对动物来说不是很罕见吗？我以为动物通常是那种——速战速决。
So did I, especially insects. I don't know. I think it's somewhat rare. I was surprised. I've waited four hours and finally just went to bed and woke up in the morning. And the male was nowhere to be found. But then, one time, instead of him getting completely off of her, she caught him and wrapped her arms around him like she was holding him round the neck, like locking arm-in-arm, and she started eating him. Couldn't believe it. I've mated them two years in a row now and hadn't had them do that.
我也这么认为，特别是昆虫。我不知道。我觉得这有点罕见。我很惊讶。我等了四个小时，最后只能去睡觉，早上醒来时，雄性已经不知去向了。但有一次，他并没有完全从她身上下来，她抓住了他，双臂环抱住他，就像抱着他的脖子，就像手臂锁在一起一样，然后她开始吃他。简直不敢相信。我连续两年让它们交配，还没见过它们那样做。
The photos aren't exactly grisly. There's no blood, not really even any color. But they're still pretty disturbing.
照片并不完全是可怕的。没有血，甚至几乎没有任何颜色。但它们仍然相当令人不安。
You see, he's still halfway on, and she reached around and grabbed him by the neck and bit his face off. See, he has no head there.
你看，他还半截在身上，而她伸手过来，抓住他的脖子，把他的脸咬掉了。你看，他那里没有头。
What's that?
那是什么？
Oh, that's one of his arms. There was kind of a fight. It's like the tip somewhere. And she's eating straight down his abdomen. See? He's already past his waist. She finished when she got there. She even ate some of the wings, munched on some of those.
噢，那是他的一条手臂。当时打了一架。那是尖端的某个部位。她正在顺着他的腹部往下吃。看到没？他已经过了腰部。她到那儿时就停下了。她甚至吃掉了一些翅膀，啃掉了一些。
And when does he die?
他是什么时候死的？
When does he die?
Do you think he's dead there?
你觉得他在那儿已经死了吗？
Well, insects, it's like their bodies are more democratic. They don't have a central nervous system the same way we do. You bite their head off, and the whole theory is that their body keeps functioning. So she can bite his head off when they're in this position having sex, and he continues to have sex with her and continues to give her sperm, which is why-- or whatever they call it in bug stuff.
好吧，昆虫，就像它们的身体更民主一样。它们没有我们那样的中枢神经系统。你把它们的头咬掉，整个理论就是它们的身体会继续运作。所以她可以在它们处于交配姿势时咬掉他的头，他还会继续与她进行性交，继续给她精子，这就是为什么——或者无论在虫子世界里这叫什么。
And there were some scientists who measured the inside of her cavity, and when she bit his head off, she got more sperm. So his head actually acted as an inhibitor. And when that's gone, she gets the rest. So in the cases where the female bit the head off, she actually got more sperm. I suppose theoretically, therefore, more of her eggs are fertilized.
而且有一些科学家测量了她的体腔内部，当她咬掉他的头时，她得到了更多的精子。所以他的头实际上起到了抑制作用。而当它消失后，她得到了剩下的部分。所以在雌性咬掉头的情况下，她实际上得到了更多的精子。我想理论上，因此她的卵子有更多受精了。
What do you mean his head acts as an inhibitor?
你说的他的头起到抑制作用是什么意思？
He's very cautious around her. And his caution seems to originate in his head. So at this point, he's definitely still alive when she's only eaten his face off.
他在她身边非常谨慎。他的谨慎似乎源于他的头。所以在那一刻，当她只咬掉了他的脸时，他绝对还活着。
At the center of Catherine's studio, there are two glass cages where her mice live. There are about 20 mice in each cage of all ages. Some have just been born, still nursing from their mothers, some pregnant, some have been around for a few generations. It's the nicest part of the studio. The mice are all very clean and healthy and cute. And the cage even smells good. These mice are the centerpiece of Catherine's current project. She photographs them being born, and then photographs them being eaten by various predators.
在凯瑟琳工作室的中心，有两个玻璃笼子，里面住着她的老鼠。每个笼子里大约有20只不同年龄的老鼠。有的刚出生，还在吮吸母亲的乳汁，有的怀孕了，有的已经繁衍了好几代。这是工作室里最美好的一部分。老鼠们都非常干净、健康而且可爱。甚至笼子里闻起来都很香。这些老鼠是凯瑟琳当前项目的核心。她拍摄它们出生的过程，然后拍摄它们被各种捕食者吃掉的过程。
Today, she's going to take pictures of a two-day-old mouse, which is called a "pinkie" because it's too young to have fur. It just has pink skin. Its eyes are still closed, and it can barely move. Her 10-inch, pencil-thin snake, Pumpkin, hasn't eaten in almost a week. Today, Pumpkin's going to eat a pinkie.
今天，她要拍摄一只两天大的小老鼠，它被称为“粉红仔”，因为它还太小，没有毛。它只有粉红色的皮肤。它的眼睛还闭着，几乎动弹不得。她那条10英寸长、铅笔般细的蛇，南瓜，已经快一个星期没吃东西了。今天，南瓜要吃掉一只粉红仔。
She puts the pinkie and the snake up on what she calls her set. This is where she takes all the pictures. It's chest high, about three feet by three feet with a white Formica surface that curves up at the back to form a seamless background. There are only two strobe lights, plus the third light underneath the surface to make sure the animals stay warm.
她把粉红仔和蛇放在她所谓的“布景”上。这就是她拍摄所有照片的地方。它有胸部那么高，大约三英尺乘三英尺，有一个白色的福米卡表面，后面向上弯曲形成一个无缝的背景。只有两盏频闪灯，加上表面下方的第三盏灯，以确保动物们保持温暖。
Do you have to keep the snake away from the pinkie when you first put it down?
当你第一次把蛇放下去的时候，你必须让蛇远离粉红仔吗？
No, it takes a while to figure out that it's there.
不，它需要一点时间来发现那儿有什么。
Now, the pinkie started moving. Do you think--
现在，粉红仔开始动了。你觉得——
No, I don't think the pinkie understands there's a snake there.
不，我不觉得粉红仔知道那儿有条蛇。
The snake's moving slowly, putting its head up right next to the pinkie and flicking out its tongue as if it wants to lick it.
蛇在缓慢移动，把头伸到离粉红仔很近的地方，吐出舌头，好像它想舔它一样。
She's checking it out, smelling it, sniffing it, making sure it's OK, I guess.
它在检查它，闻闻它，嗅嗅它，确保它没问题，我想。
It's very friendly.
它看起来很友好。
I don't know if I'd call  it friendly.
我不知道我会不会称它为友好。
It just looks that way, the two of them together.
看起来就是那样，它们两个在一起。
The two of them hanging out together, yeah. Their faces are about the same size-- well, no, the mouse's face is bigger. You see what I mean? There's no terror in the mouse.
它们两个待在一起，是的。它们的脸大小差不多——好吧，不，老鼠的脸更大。你明白我的意思吗？老鼠身上没有恐惧。
But the mouse doesn't look that happy.
但老鼠看起来并不那么开心。
Hard to tell what makes something that small that happy.
很难说是什么让那么小的东西感到开心。
We stood there for 15 minutes watching as the snake tried to decide what to do. The pinkie didn't move much, just sort of quivered, raising its head every once in a while. Then, finally, the snake made its move.
我们站在那儿看了15分钟，看着蛇试图决定该做什么。粉红仔没怎么动，只是有点颤抖，偶尔抬头看一眼。然后，最后，蛇采取了行动。
Hmm. Very strange.
嗯。非常奇怪。
What was strange was the way the snake attacked. Pumpkin is a constrictor, which means that usually, when it goes for its prey, it quickly wraps its body around it and squeezes it to death.
奇怪的是蛇攻击的方式。南瓜是一条蟒蛇，这意味着通常情况下，当它去抓捕猎物时，它会迅速将身体缠绕在猎物身上并将其勒死。
Hasn't happened like this before.
以前没发生过这种情况。
This time, it bit the pinkie and held it in its fangs alive for a couple of minutes before it finally constricted it.
这次，它咬住了粉红仔，并用毒牙含住活着的它几分钟，然后才把它勒死。
Does the pinkie always struggle like that?
粉红仔总是会那样挣扎吗？
No, and it has never squealed before.
不，而且它以前从未尖叫过。
What's the difference, do you think?
你认为有什么不同吗？
Pinkie was bigger, older.
那只粉红仔更大，更老。
Is it still alive now?
它现在还活着吗？
You look at the tail, you can usually tell. See, when the tail starts to droop down. Although it's getting so much blood pushed through there that that could keep it out.
你看尾巴，你通常就能看出来。你看，当尾巴开始下垂的时候。虽然它输送了这么多血液，可能会让它看起来还有活力。
I know you can be charged for being cruel to a dog. Can you be charged for being cruel to a mouse?
我知道虐待狗会被指控。虐待老鼠会被指控吗？
No, I don't think so. Now, maybe if I took one of my mice, went out into the middle of Broadway and started ripping it apart where everybody could see-- I don't know. And probably a legal person wouldn't know, because it never comes up.
不，我不觉得。现在，也许如果我带着我的一只老鼠，走到百老汇大街中间，在大家都能看到的地方把它撕碎——我不知道。法律人士可能也不知道，因为它从来没发生过。
Catherine says that we've developed a hierarchy of death. Some animals, we're prohibited from killing, some, we're encouraged to kill, and most of them, we just don't care about. I asked her whether doing The Food Chain project changed the way she saw animals, and she said that it hadn't changed the way she saw them, it made her see them for the first time. Before she started photographing animals, she was like most people. She never really thought about them at all.
凯瑟琳说我们已经发展出了一套死亡等级制度。有些动物我们被禁止杀死，有些我们被鼓励杀死，而大多数我们根本不在乎。我问她进行“食物链”项目是否改变了她看待动物的方式，她说这并没有改变她看待它们的方式，而是让她第一次真正看到了它们。在她开始拍摄动物之前，她和大多数人一样。她从来没有真正考虑过它们。
And do you ever feel like you're taking sides when you set up a photograph like this?
那么当你布置这样的照片时，你是否觉得你在站队？
Yeah, your sides change. At one point, you feel really bad about the pinkie, and at one point, you're really happy your snake ate, and therefore it's really and it's going to live. In something like this, your sides always change. And when you put the pinkie up there before you put the snake up there, you feel really bad. You think, "Oh, well, this little thing doesn't know it's about to be eaten."
是的，你的立场会变。在某一刻，你对那只粉红仔感到非常难过，而在另一刻，你又为你蛇吃了东西而感到非常高兴，因此它很好，它要活下去了。在这样的事情中，你的立场总是在变。当你把蛇放上去之前把粉红仔放上去时，你感觉真的很糟糕。你会想：“哦，好吧，这个小东西不知道它快要被吃掉了。”
And with The Food Chain project, that was one of the points is that you take the side of the underdog. And then the underdog becomes a predator, and then you have to change sides again, and then you change sides again. I mean, it's arbitrary and relative anyway. So you just kind of get all confused, really.
而在“食物链”项目中，其中一个观点就是你站在弱者这边。然后弱者变成了捕食者，然后你又不得不换边站，然后你又换边站。我的意思是，这无论如何都是武断和相对的。所以你基本上就感到很困惑，真的。
It's getting to the point with the mouse project where those feelings are starting to have real repercussions. Right now, Pumpkin can't eat anything bigger than a pinkie. But she's growing. Eventually, she'll be three feet or more. Before long, she'll be eating full-grown mice, the ones that Catherine feeds and holds and plays with every day.
老鼠项目已经到了这种地步，那些感觉开始产生真实的影响。现在，南瓜不能吃比粉红仔更大的东西。但她在长大。最终，她会长到三英尺或更长。用不了多久，她就会吃掉长大的老鼠，就是凯瑟琳每天喂养、抱在怀里玩耍的那些老鼠。
It's one thing to feed-- I was telling you this before-- to feed something to something where the pinkie has no senses yet, or it can't see. It can smell, but it can't see. But it's another when you pick up a full-grown mouse, who is aware of what's going on when it sees a snake. And I don't know what I'm going to do when she starts eating full-grown mice. Right now, it's still something within the realm of something I can do. I don't know. Is there a line at which it starts being hard to do? Yeah, probably.
喂养——我之前跟你说过这个——把东西喂给还没长出感官或者看不到的东西是一回事。它能闻到，但它看不到。但当你拿起一只长大的老鼠，它在看到蛇时知道发生了什么，那是另一回事。当她开始吃长大的老鼠时，我不知道我会做什么。现在，它还在我可以做到的范围内。我不知道。是不是有一个界限，一旦超过了就变得很难做了？是的，大概吧。
Catherine talks about her apartment being like an oasis in the middle of SoHo. She loves coming home from the cars and concrete of Manhattan into a place that's filled with life. But in another way, it's Manhattan. It's our world that's the oasis in the middle of a planet that's full of nature. All around us, things are eating and having sex and dying and suffering. And we don't notice or even think about it.
凯瑟琳谈到她的公寓就像苏荷区中间的一片绿洲。她喜欢从曼哈顿的汽车和混凝土中回到一个充满生命的地方。但从另一方面看，这就是曼哈顿。是我们世界在这个充满自然的世界中间的一片绿洲。在我们周围，万物都在进食、交配、死亡和受苦。而我们根本没有注意到，甚至没有去想它。
Do you think the pinkie's still alive?
你觉得粉红仔还活着吗？
No. It's getting kind of blue.
不。它开始有点变蓝了。
So did you feel weird at all when he was squealing at the end? Did that make you feel strange at all?
那你最后听到它尖叫的时候，有没有觉得有点奇怪？那让你感觉有什么异样吗？
Well, you never really like something to suffer. I definitely was not very happy. But the pinkie was going to die anyway.
好吧，你永远不会真的喜欢看到东西受苦。我绝对非常不高兴。但粉红仔反正也要死。
I guess there's a difference if it's being fed, if there's a purpose to it, if it's part of the chain.
我想如果它是作为食物，如果这样做是有目的的，如果它是链条的一部分，那还是有区别的。
It's no different to the snake. The snake doesn't really seem to care if the mouse squeals or not. Is it any different to the mouse? Yeah, maybe a little bit. But it's dying anyway. It dies a little faster or it dies a little slower, possibly. I cared more. The snake didn't care. Who knows if the mouse did. So who matters? Whose opinion do I go by here? Why should I go by mine?
对于蛇来说没什么区别。蛇似乎并不关心老鼠是否尖叫。对于老鼠来说有什么区别吗？是的，也许有一点。但它反正都要死。它死得快一点或者慢一点，可能吧。我在乎得多。蛇不在乎。谁知道老鼠在不在乎。那么谁重要呢？我该听从谁的意见？我为什么要听从我自己的意见？
At the end of our photo shoot, Catherine carefully picks up the snake and carries it back to its cage. There's a bulge about a third of the way down the snake's body where the pinkie is being digested. Before I leave, Catherine pours us a glass of wine, and we sit on the floor for a little while playing with a couple of her full-grown mice, letting them run over our hands and up our arms. They're tiny and warm, and through their fur, we can feel their little hearts beating.
在我们的摄影结束时，凯瑟琳小心地拿起蛇，把它带回笼子里。蛇的身体下方大约三分之一处有一个隆起，那是粉红仔正在被消化。在我离开之前，凯瑟琳给我们倒了一杯酒，我们坐在地板上玩了一会儿她的几只长大的老鼠，让它们在我们的手上和手臂上跑来跑去。它们很小而且温暖，透过它们的皮毛，我们可以感觉到它们的小心脏在跳动。
[MUSIC - "INSECT COLLECTOR" BY SHONEN KNIFE]
[音乐 - 少年刀乐队的《昆虫收集者》]
Paul Tough. Catherine Chalmers' pictures are in a book called Food Chain: Encounters Between Mates, Predators, and Prey.
保罗·托夫。凯瑟琳·查尔莫斯的照片收录在《食物链：配偶、捕食者与猎物之间的邂逅》一书中。
Coming up, animal radio theater by David Sedaris, animal research by Scott Carrier. That's all in a minute, from Public Radio International, when our program continues.
接下来的节目，大卫·塞达里斯的动物广播剧，斯科特·卡里尔的动物研究。这些都将在公共广播国际的节目中为您呈现，稍后继续。
It's This American Life . I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our program, of course, we choose a topic and tackle that topic with documentaries, short fiction, radio monologues, found tape, anything we can think of. Today's topic, Animals. Animals and the Animal-ness of Animals. We have arrived at Act Two of our program, which basically, it's more animals eating other animals.
这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。每周在我们的节目中，当然，我们都会选择一个主题，并用纪录片、短篇小说、广播独白、找到的录音等任何我们能想到的方式来处理这个主题。今天的主题，动物。动物与动物的“动物性”。我们已经到了节目的第二幕，基本上，就是更多动物吃掉其他动物。
But first, a little story. A little girl is given a new sweater-- an ugly new sweater, which she hates. She takes the sweater, puts it on the floor, takes a nap, and when she wakes up, her sweater's been chewed to shreds. She, of course, could not be happier, but her mother's very upset, cries a little. The girl blames the dog. The dog. A little spaniel named Kathleen.
但首先，一个小故事。一个小女孩得到了一件新毛衣——一件她很讨厌的丑毛衣。她拿着毛衣，把它放在地上，睡了一觉，当她醒来时，她的毛衣已经被嚼得稀巴烂。她当然开心极了，但她的母亲非常难过，还哭了。女孩责怪了狗。那只狗。一只叫凯瑟琳的小猎犬。
I demand a fair hearing. I won't take the blame.
我要求公平听证。我不会背这个锅。
Kathleen the spaniel then stood to proclaim.
猎犬凯瑟琳随后站出来宣称。
I didn't do nothing. I'm just not the sort. I'll see you in hell first, or animal court.
我什么都没做。我根本不是那种狗。我会先在地狱见你，或者在动物法庭见。
David Sedaris has written a play for our program. This play is an original radio play entirely in rhymed couplets. In this play, the animals do lots of things that humans do. For example, they talk. And they hold court out in the forest. But in this play, also, every now and then, unlike most fairy tales and like most movies about animals or stories about animals, these animals reassert their animal-ness.
大卫·塞达里斯为我们的节目写了一部戏。这部戏是一部完全使用押韵对句的原创广播剧。在这部戏里，动物们做了很多人类做的事情。例如，它们会说话。它们还在森林里开庭。但在这部戏里，每隔一段时间，与大多数童话故事不同，像大多数关于动物的电影或故事一样，这些动物重新申明了它们的“动物性”。
Our play begins as Kathleen the Spaniel heads out into the forest, and our narrator-- the little girl who owns her-- follows behind.
我们的戏从猎犬凯瑟琳走向森林开始，而我们的讲述者——拥有它的那个小女孩——跟在后面。
I waited til late and crept out. It was dark. I was deep in the forest when I heard a bark. It was Kathleen, my spaniel, kneeling before an old dog-- a judge. And this elder, he wore a dark, floor-length robe. I think it was silk. He paused then and lapped from a bowl of skim milk.
我等到很晚才溜出去。天很黑。我在森林深处时听到了叫声。是凯瑟琳，我的猎犬，跪在一条老狗面前——那是个法官。这位长者穿着一件深色的长袍。我想是丝绸做的。他停了一下，从一个碗里舔了舔脱脂牛奶。
This court is in session. Oh, Jesus. I ought to lay off the scraps when they serve enchiladas.
现在开庭。噢，上帝。他们上辣酱玉米饼馅的时候我真该少吃点剩饭。
He patted his chest with potato-sized paws, then pounded his gavel and laid down the law.
他用土豆大小的爪子拍了拍胸口，然后猛敲木槌，定下了规矩。
There'll be no witnesses leading, no swearing or shedding, no tampering, cat calls, or evidence shredding. I call on the state now to start prosecution. Defense will then counter to prove absolution.
不准证人引导，不准发誓或脱毛，不准篡改、猫叫或销毁证据。现在我要求州方开始起诉。辩方随后将进行反驳以证明免罪。
The clearing was silent. A cat took the floor, a smooth-talking tom with a high pompadour.
空地上很安静。一只猫站了出来，一只说话圆滑、梳着高耸发型（蓬巴杜发型）的公猫。
Your honor, destruction's no small misdemeanor. The accused here is vicious. We should quarantine her. Now I plan to prove beyond reasonable doubt that Kathleen the spaniel engaged in a bout of senseless destruction. She's got no remorse, a fact that I'm hoping to prove in due course. I call to the stand now one eyewitness worm. She was there on the scene. Her memory's firm.
法官大人，破坏不是什么轻微的轻罪。被告在这里很残忍。我们应该把她隔离。我现在计划在合理怀疑之外证明，猎犬凯瑟琳进行了一场毫无意义的破坏。她毫无悔意，这是我希望在适当时候证明的事实。现在我传唤一位目击证人，一条虫子。她就在现场。她的记忆很准确。
It seemed like a lifetime. The worm took forever to inch to the stand and begin her endeavor.
仿佛过了一辈子。那条虫子花了好久才挪向证人席，开始她的努力。
Yes, I'm a worm, true. I live in the soil. Only in rain do I earthwards unfoil. On this day in question, we had a fierce shower. So using my well-known abdominal power, I lifted myself from the earth's muddy ground. I crawled and I climbed and eventually found myself on a window ledge-- me, just a worm, a fact I would now like to briefly confirm. My eyesight is faultless. I know what I'd seen.
是的，我是条虫子，没错。我住在土壤里。只有下雨时我才钻出地面。在问题的这一天，我们下了一场大雨。所以利用我众所周知的腹部力量，我从泥泞的地上抬起了自己。我爬着，攀着，最后发现自己在窗台上——我，只是一条虫子，这是我现在想简要证实的事实。我的视力没问题。我知道我看到了什么。
The defendant herself, the spaniel Kathleen, engaged in destruction against the same sweater. She used it as a sort of appetite whetter. She gnawed at the fabric and tugged at the collar. And knowing no way I could stop her or stall her, I stood, a mute witness. I watched in disgust. I think it's appalling. I find it unjust. That dog's no puppy.
被告本人，猎犬凯瑟琳，对那件毛衣进行了破坏。她把它当作一种开胃菜。她啃着布料，拽着领口。我不知道有什么办法能阻止或拖延她，我站着，是个沉默的目击者。我厌恶地看着。我觉得这太令人震惊了。我觉得这不公正。那只狗不是小狗。
She should've known better than to lie on a mattress digesting a sweater. If you want my opinion, I think you ought to put her away. She's a heinous marauder.
她早该知道不该躺在床垫上消化毛衣。如果你问我的意见，我觉得你应该把她关起来。她是个令人发指的掠夺者。
The worm had concluded. She'd finished her say, and reached for a thimble of cold consomme.
虫子说完了。她完成了她的陈述，伸手去拿一个顶针的凉汤。
Your witness.
证人交给你了。
The cat said. I watched as a wren hopped to the floor where the cat once had been.
猫说。我看着一只鹪鹩跳到了猫刚才所在的地板上。
Your honor, it's clear that this worm is deceptive. I'm wondering now if she might be receptive to proving her eyesight is all that she claims. I'd like her to read from this short list of names.
法官大人，很明显这条虫子是在撒谎。我很好奇她是否能证明她的视力真像她所说的那样。我想让她从这张名字清单上读出名字。
The bird took a book written in Lebanese and carried it out past the pond to the trees.
鸟儿拿出一本用黎巴嫩语写的书，带着它飞过池塘，一直到树边。
Can you read this name here. It's first on the list.
你能读一下这个名字吗。这是名单上的第一个。
That's too far away,
太远了，
The angry worm hissed.
愤怒的虫子嘶嘶叫道。
I can't read that far, not even in day. You might as well post it in Rome or Pompeii.
我读不了那么远，哪怕是在白天。你还不如把它贴在罗马或庞贝。
So your sight--
所以你的视力——
Said the bird, keen on proving a point.
那只鸟说，热衷于证明观点。
--is something you boast upon when you anoint this court with your presence, the all-seeing worm. Your sight is on par with an old pachyderm. You're small and deceitful. You crawled to no ledge. You witnessed no crime like the one you allege.
——就是你在出席本法庭时夸耀的东西，全能的虫子。你的视力和一只老厚皮动物（象）相当。你又小又阴险。你没有爬到什么窗台上。你没看到任何你所指控的那种犯罪。
Stop talking to me in your harsh legalese. I know what I saw. I can't read Lebanese. Still, though, I saw it. I've seen lots of things. I've noticed you poach and take off on your wings. I know all about you. My word is my honor.
别用你那刺耳的法律术语跟我说话。我知道我看到了什么。我读不懂黎巴嫩语。不过，我看到了。我看到过很多东西。我注意到你盗猎并在翅膀上起飞。我什么都知道。我的话就是我的荣誉。
She looked at the bird then, a certified goner. The wren whispered softly, as if to confirm, and then she lunged forward, beheading the worm.
她看着那只鸟，那是个注定的倒霉蛋。鹪鹩轻轻地低语，仿佛为了确认，然后她猛扑向前，把虫子斩首了。
Objection!
反对！
The cat yelled.
猫喊道。
She's eating my witness!
她在吃我的证人！
The bird, in a grand show of physical fitness, finished the worm and returned to her perch, the lowest-hung branch of a young, silver birch.
那只鸟，在展示了伟大的身体素质后，吃完了虫子，回到了她的栖息地，一棵年轻的银桦树最下方的树枝上。
The cat called a witness, a chubby, black cricket I'd seen once or twice in my room eat a ticket to movies or plays. This thing, it ate paper. Its body was small, just the size of a caper.
猫传唤了一名证人，一只胖乎乎的黑蟋蟀，我曾一两次在我的房间里看到它吃掉去电影院或剧院的票。这个东西，它吃纸。它的身体很小，只有刺山柑那么大。
I'm a cricket, I am. And to hell with your court.
我是只蟋蟀，我是。去你的法庭。
Said the cricket, her vocal cords fierce in retort.
蟋蟀说，她的声带激烈地反驳着。
I've no use for your system. It's false and oppressive. The lawyer's behavior is passive-aggressive. You're saying you want me to be more specific? I tell you, I find your whole species horrific. We live day to day, us and grasshoppers too. You bark and you chirp, you low or you mew, then head to your nest for a night's hibernation while we're out there fighting for true liberation. You rise from your beds and meet in this clearing to practice your justice. It's all profiteering.
我不需要你们的系统。它是虚伪和压迫性的。律师的行为是被动攻击型的。你说你想让我更具体一点？我告诉你，我觉得你们整个物种都很可怕。我们过着一天算一天的生活，我们和蚱蜢也是。你们吠叫、啁啾、喵喵叫，然后头也不回地回到巢穴冬眠，而我们却在外为真正的解放而战。你们从床上爬起来，在这个空地上会面，练习你们的公正。这全是投机取巧。
Your system's disgusting. It's rotten and stinky. And if you think I'll raise my right hand or my pinkie in honor to you, then you are quite mistaken. I saw something, true. But no statement I'm making. I won't say a word til you promise protection.
你们的系统令人作呕。它是腐烂和恶臭的。如果你认为我会向你举起右手或小指表示敬意，那你就大错特错了。我确实看到了东西，没错。但我不会发表任何声明。在你们承诺保护我之前，我一个字也不会说。
Contempt!
蔑视法庭！
Cried the bird. The cat yelled,
鸟哭喊道。猫喊道，
Objection!
反对！
This justice you claim, it's all based on species. I'd rather kneel down on the ground and eat feces than kowtow to you and your justice achieving. I'm no friend of yours. Do you hear me? I'm leaving.
你们所声称的这种公正，完全是基于物种的。我宁愿跪在地上吃粪便，也不愿向你们和你们的公正屈服。我不是你们的朋友。听到了吗？我要走了。
The court was in chaos. The cricket hopped off. She flew through the air just like Baryshnikov. The bird then, she followed it into the thicket, and returned having eaten that hot-tempered cricket. There was no objection, no cry of foul play. The judge and the lawyers gave a silent OK.
法庭一片混乱。蟋蟀跳走了。她飞在空中，就像巴雷什尼科夫一样。那只鸟随后跟进了灌木丛，回来时已经吃掉了那只脾气暴躁的蟋蟀。没有人提出反对，没有人叫喊犯规。法官和律师们沉默地点了点头。
Next witness.
下一位证人。
The judge barked.
法官吠道。
Allow me to mention we're holding this court with the sole good intention of seeking the truth, of meriting justice. It helps when you call up a witness who will trust us.
允许我提一下，我们召开这个法庭的唯一目的是寻求真相，获得公正。当你传唤一个会信任我们的证人时，这会有所帮助。
Your honor--
法官大人——
The bird said.
鸟说。
--I now call a squirrel, a trustworthy witness, a very nice girl. Hardworking and thrifty, she lives in that elm. I'm hoping my colleague will not overwhelm or badger my witness. She's timid and shy.
——我现在传唤一只松鼠，一个值得信任的证人，一个非常好的女孩。她勤劳节俭，住在那棵榆树上。我希望我的同事不会压迫或纠缠我的证人。她很胆小。
The judge took an aspirin and shouted out--
法官吃了一片阿司匹林，大喊道——
Why don't you bring on this witness. Enough of your chatter. Let's hope that this squirrel can finish the matter. I'm tired and hungry, so please let's proceed.
你为什么不把这位证人带上来。你们的闲话够多了。让我们希望这只松鼠能结束这件事。我累了也饿了，所以请继续吧。
The cat took a watch from his pocket.
猫从口袋里拿出一块表。
Indeed, you're stalling this court with your warbling and rambling. I'm thinking, your honor, defense is just gambling. She's playing for time. It's a transparent tactic. Some call it clever. I call it didactic.
确实，你用你的颤音和胡言乱语拖延法庭的时间。我正在想，法官大人，辩方只是在赌博。她在争取时间。这是一种透明的策略。有人称之为聪明。我称之为教学。
Your honor, forgive me. I call your attention to my leading witness, that squirrel I mentioned.
法官大人，请原谅。我提请您注意我的主要证人，就是我提到的那只松鼠。
There was no need to prompt her, no need to coerce the squirrel into talking. She set down her purse, and crossing her legs-- ladylike, at the shin-- the squirrel eyewitness began to weigh in.
没有必要提示她，没有必要强迫松鼠说话。她放下手提包，盘起腿——淑女般地盘在小腿处——松鼠目击者开始发表意见。
I saw it, I did. The whole thing. And it reeks. I was sitting there calmly with nuts in my cheeks. I gather them daily. These nuts are my diet. An acorn, a pecan, you name it, I'll try it. Sometimes I'll hide them. I'll dig them a grave for some later time when we have a cold wave. It ain't easy digging through thick ice and snow.
我看到了，我确实看到了。整件事。真是臭气熏天。我当时正安静地坐在那儿，脸颊里塞着坚果。我每天都在收集它们。这些坚果是我的食物。橡子，胡桃，随便你怎么说，我都会尝尝。有时我会把它们藏起来。我会把它们埋在坟墓里，留到以后寒潮来袭时再吃。在厚厚的冰雪中挖掘可不容易。
Objection.
反对。
The cat cried.
猫喊道。
I think we all know that winter is frosty, it's chilly, and tough. In terms of her hardship, we've all heard enough.
我想我们都知道冬天是霜冻的、寒冷的、艰难的。关于她的艰辛，我们听得够多了。
Get on with your story. Enough of your woes.
继续说你的故事吧。你的苦难够多了。
Yes, sir,
是的，先生，
Said the squirrel.
松鼠说。
Well, the rest of it goes, I was searching for food then, was out on my rounds. My sister remarked that I gained a few pounds in my hips and my shoulders. She thought it looked smashing. I respect her opinion, and so I was dashing to something I saw. It resembled a kernel of corn, so I thought. But it seems the infernal nugget in question turned out to be gum. It was chewed in a wad just the size of a crumb. I was out of my mind then. I wanted a snack.
好吧，剩下的情况是，我当时正在寻找食物，正在巡逻。我的姐妹评论说我的臀部和肩膀长了些肉。她认为这看起来棒极了。我尊重她的意见，所以我当时正冲向我看到的东西。它像一颗玉米粒，我是这么想的。但似乎那个所谓的内生金块结果是口香糖。它被嚼成一团，只有碎屑大小。我当时疯了。我想要一份零食。
Objection, your honor. She's getting off track,
反对，法官大人。她跑题了，
The cat lawyer cried.
猫律师喊道。
Let's get on with the crime.
让我们继续说犯罪本身。
Your honor--
法官大人——
The bird said.
鸟说。
--my witness needs time to set up her scene of emotional stress. She's said to have suffered from mental duress.
——我的证人需要时间来铺陈她的情绪压力场景。据说她患有精神困苦。
So anyway, right, if my memory serves, I was searching the ground for some type of hors d'oeurve when I heard in the distance the sound of a voice. It sounded quite angry, so I made the choice. I peeked through the window and sat on my haunches, and then I became, for a brief while, unconscious.
所以，好吧，如果我的记忆没出错，我当时正在地上寻找某种开胃菜，这时我听到了远处传来一个声音。听起来很愤怒，所以我做出了选择。我通过窗户偷看，坐在后腿上，然后我变得，在那一小会儿，失去了知觉。
It happens, sometimes. I have these brief spells. I can't say for certain, but something compels my brain to relax, causing me to black out. I was hit in the head with a large brussels sprout last summer. I think it was early July. I think that's the reason. I'm not certain why.
这种事有时会发生。我有这种短暂的眩晕。我不能说得太肯定，但有什么东西迫使我的大脑放松，导致我昏倒。去年夏天，我的头被一个巨大的抱子甘蓝击中了。我想那是七月初。我想那就是原因。我不确定为什么。
I'm sorry--
对不起——
The cat said.
猫说。
--your mind is so frail. I'm wondering, though, if your story entails the fact of this case? Is there any connection between the accused and your brain imperfection?
——你的心智如此脆弱。不过，我很想知道，你的故事是否与本案的事实有关？被告和你的大脑缺陷之间有什么联系吗？
Technically, yes,
从技术上讲，是的，
The squirrel said, beaming.
松鼠说着，笑逐颜开。
My body was there, but my mind was dreaming. I was there at the scene. That I know for a fact. I was hoping by speaking I might could extract some details, something I maybe could mention to justify all of this lavish attention. I find it exciting, dramatic, suspense. It all suits me perfect because, in a sense, I enjoy public speaking. I love center stage.
我的身体在那里，但我的心智在做梦。我确实在现场。这一点我很清楚。我希望能通过发言来提取一些细节，一些我或许可以提到的东西，以证明所有这些奢侈的关注。我觉得这很刺激、很戏剧化、很有悬念。这对我来说再合适不过了，因为在某种意义上，我喜欢公开演讲。我热爱舞台中心。
The bird then approached, feathers standing in rage.
那只鸟随后靠近，羽毛在愤怒中竖起。
You said you had seen things, that you were compliant, and had information concerning my client.
你说过你看到了东西，你很顺从，并且掌握关于我当事人的信息。
I might have, you know, but I can't say for certain. I know what I told you, but now I'm revertin'. Is this microphone on? Hello? Do you mind if I sing?
我可能掌握，你知道的，但我不能肯定。我知道我告诉过你什么，但现在我反悔了。这个麦克风开了吗？你好？你介意我唱歌吗？
The bird slapped the stand with the tip of her wing and spat in disgust.
鸟用翼尖猛击支架，厌恶地吐了口唾沫。
Your witness.
证人交给你了。
She said. The cat flexed his paws, and then used them to shred that squirrel to ribbons. He tore it to bits and ate everything but her eyes and armpits. And then he pounced forward and firmly procured between his firm jaws that lawyering bird.
她说。猫舒展了爪子，然后用它们把那只松鼠撕成了碎片。他把它撕得支离破碎，除了眼睛和腋下，什么都吃了。然后他猛扑向前，用坚硬的下颚牢牢地抓住了那只当律师的鸟。
Objection, your honor. I feel I'm being eaten. I don't like the way my colleague is treatin' the legal profession, especially me. I'm soon to become a full-fledged amputee.
反对，法官大人。我觉得我快被吃了。我不喜欢我的同事对待法律职业的方式，特别是对待我。我很快就要成为一个彻底的截肢者了。
That was all that I heard. The rest was too muffled. I watched for a while as the two of them scuffled. The cat took the bird right down to the beak. The judge rose, then asking if now he might speak.
这就是我听到的全部。其余的声音太模糊了。我看着他们纠缠了一会儿。猫直接把鸟带到了喙部。法官站起来，问现在是否可以让他说话。
To the cat in my chambers, a brief legal chat.
对在我办公室里的猫，进行简短的法律聊天。
The judge then walked off and I watched as the cat foolishly followed that judge past a stump to a field of tires once used as a dump. I heard the cat hiss, then. I heard him yell, "No." I can't say for certain who struck the first blow. But I can say who won. I know that the judge stepped out of his chambers unable to budge. He belched and he sagged, both lips heavy with fur, and looked out at the courtroom where others once were.
法官随后走开了，我看着那只猫愚蠢地跟着那个法官，越过一根树桩，来到一个曾经用作垃圾场的轮胎场。我听到猫嘶嘶叫着。我听到他大喊：“不。”我无法确定是谁先出的手。但我可以说谁赢了。我知道法官走出他的办公室时无法动弹。他打了个饱嗝，身体下垂，嘴唇上沾满了毛发，看着曾经有别人在的那个法庭。
I find you not guilty.
我判你无罪。
He said to my spaniel.
他对我的猎犬说。
But if I ever hear so much as a granule of trouble from you, then I'll put you away.
但如果我再听到你哪怕有一丁点儿麻烦，我就把你关起来。
Thank you, your honor.
谢谢你，法官大人。
I heard Kathleen say.
我听到凯瑟琳说。
Go on now, get out of here. Hurry along. Get back to your home, back to where you belong.
走吧，离开这儿。快点走。回到你的家里，回到你应该在的地方。
I waited for Kathleen beside a small creek. She passed me, despondent, refusing to speak. And me, I returned to my comfortable bed thinking of how, by some fluke, I'd been led to animal court, that harsh, hostile scene, that by chance, thought to spare my companion, Kathleen.
我在小溪边等凯瑟琳。她沮丧地从我身边经过，拒绝说话。而我，回到了舒适的床上，思考着，由于某种侥幸，我是如何被引导到动物法庭，那个严酷、充满敌意的场景，又是多么巧合地想赦免我的同伴，凯瑟琳。
The Pinetree Gang. Amy Sedaris, David Rakoff, Toby Wherry, Stacy Goldstein, Jackie Hoffman, [? Nora Ladonnie, ?] [? Sara Tyre, ?] and Richard Zaragoza. Story by David Sedaris.
松树帮。艾米·塞达里斯，大卫·拉科夫，托比·惠里，斯泰西·戈尔茨坦，杰基·霍夫曼，[？诺拉·拉多尼，？] [？萨拉·泰尔，？] 和理查德·萨拉戈萨。大卫·塞达里斯的故事。
[MUSIC - "ROCKY RACCOON" BY LENA HORNE]
[音乐 - 莉娜·霍恩的《洛基浣熊》]
Act Three, The Moment When Humans Stopped Being Animals. If you ask anthropologists, the moment that humans divide off from the animal kingdom is the moment that our ape-like ancestors started walking upright on two legs. For people who don't believe that God created the earth in six days, that moment is our origin.
第三幕，人类停止成为动物的那一刻。如果你问人类学家，人类从动物王国中分离出来的时刻，就是我们类猿祖先开始直立行走的时刻。对于那些不相信上帝在六天内创造了地球的人来说，那一刻就是我们的起源。
That's our Book of Genesis. That is the mythic point where we began. But nobody knows why these pre-humans started walking around on two legs instead of loping around on all fours the way that most animals do. There are different theories, but no consensus among scientists.
那是我们的《创世记》。那是我们开始的神话节点。但没人知道为什么这些前人类开始用两条腿走路，而不是像大多数动物那样四肢着地跑动。有不同的理论，但科学家之间没有共识。
10 years ago, Scott Carrier decided to do some research on his own, and he made this radio report.
10年前，斯科特·卡里尔决定自己做一些研究，他制作了这个广播报道。
There they go.
它们走了。
What?
什么？
There they go. You see them crossing over there?
它们走了。你看到它们在那边穿过吗？
No.
没有。
To the right. Quite a ways away, in fact. Way out there.
向右边。事实上很远。在那儿很远。
A couple of years ago, my brother and I went to Wyoming to run down an antelope.
几年前，我和我兄弟去怀俄明州追赶一只羚羊。
I only see three over there.
我只在那边看到三只。
Well, there were about eight down there.
嗯，下面大概有八只。
It was August, and our plan was to chase one animal until it overheated and collapsed.
那是八月，我们的计划是追赶一只动物，直到它过热并倒下。
It just took off running. You want to follow it?
它直接跑了。你想跟过去吗？
That's a really big [INAUDIBLE].
那真是个大家伙[听不清]。
We had good reasons for what we were doing. One was that it seemed entirely possible. Another had to do with an argument concerning human evolution. It's a scientific argument, so it takes a few minutes to explain. Remember the scene in 2001 when an ape-man realizes he can use a bone as a weapon and murders another ape-man? And he throws the bone in the air and it becomes a space station orbiting the earth.
我们做的事是有充分理由的。一是它看起来完全有可能。另一个与关于人类进化的争论有关。这是一个科学争论，所以解释起来需要几分钟。还记得《2001太空漫游》中那个人猿意识到他可以用骨头作为武器并杀害另一个人猿的场景吗？他把骨头扔向空中，它就变成了绕地球运行的空间站。
The theory behind this scene is that we separated from the apes when we stood upright and freed our hands to make and use tools, especially weapon-type tools for hunting and killing other animals. It's called the hunting hypothesis, and there's nothing wrong with it except that we don't have any physical evidence to support it. We just haven't found any tools or weapons that are that old.
这个场景背后的理论是，当我们直立行走并解放双手去制造和使用工具，特别是用于狩猎和杀死其他动物的武器型工具时，我们就从猿类中分离出来了。这被称为“狩猎假说”，除了我们没有任何物理证据来支持它，它没什么错。我们只是还没找到那么古老的工具或武器。
Well, some of the work that my brother does as a biologist made him interested in another theory of human evolution. You might call it the running hypothesis. He believed that he and I were probably good enough runners to be able to run down big game without using any weapons at all. And he thought that if we could do it, then maybe our early ancestors could have done it, too. Shortly before we went to Wyoming, I went to see Owen Lovejoy. He teaches anthropology at Kent State University. We talked about the running hypothesis, and he thought it was pretty funny.
嗯，我兄弟作为生物学家所做的一些工作让他对人类进化的另一个理论产生了兴趣。你可以称之为“奔跑假说”。他相信他和我可能都是足够优秀的跑步者，能够不使用任何武器就追赶大型猎物。他认为如果我们能做到，那么我们早期的祖先也可能做到。在我们去怀俄明州之前不久，我去看望了欧文·洛夫乔伊。他在肯特州立大学教授人类学。我们谈到了“奔跑假说”，他觉得这很有趣。
I mean, all you have to do is think about it for a minute. What game are they going to run down? Things like a wildebeest or something?
我的意思是，你只需要花一分钟考虑一下。他们要追赶什么猎物？像角马之类的东西吗？
Mm hmm. Zebra.
嗯哼。斑马。
And they're just going to start off running after this thing without any advanced weaponry of any kind. They've got no spears, right? No bow and arrow. And they just start running after a wildebeest?
他们就要开始在没有任何先进武器的情况下追逐这个东西。他们没有长矛，对吧？没有弓箭。他们就开始跑去追角马？
Yeah, I think that's the idea that they have.
是的，我想这就是他们的想法。
The weak link in that whole behavior that you're describing is the inability of the animal to run any faster because it's so damn slow. And it's so damn slow because it's a clumsy biped. Is that an animal adapted to hunting? Slow, awkward, little, no olfaction, no protective vision?
你所描述的整个行为中薄弱的一环是动物因为太慢而无法跑得更快。它之所以那么慢，是因为它是个笨拙的双足动物。那是一种适应狩猎的动物吗？缓慢、笨拙、弱小、嗅觉不灵、没有防护视力？
If it were an effective quadruped, it could do everything that you're describing in half the time. Imagine a bunch of Paiute Indians that could run as rapidly and as successfully as a German Shepherd dog. They'd catch the thing in three minutes and devour it.
如果它是一个有效的四足动物，它就能在半时间内完成你所描述的一切。想象一群派尤特印第安人，能跑得像德国牧羊犬一样快和成功。他们会在三分钟内抓住那个东西并把它吃掉。
Well, I just happen to have a German Shepherd, and I take him with me when I go running.
嗯，我刚好有一只德国牧羊犬，我跑步时会带着他。
Let's go. [DOG BARKS]
我们走吧。[狗叫声]
And Lovejoy's right. He's a better runner than I am. In fact, most of the time, he'd rather have me take my bicycle. So there's no question about me being slower. But as far as being clumsy-- Lovejoy calls bipedalism clumsy because of reasons that have to do with biomechanics. Running bipedally takes twice as much energy as running quadrupedally. That is, when my dog and I run, he uses half the energy that I do.
洛夫乔伊说得对。他是个比我更好的跑步者。事实上，大多数时候，他宁愿我骑自行车。所以毫无疑问我跑得更慢。但说到笨拙——洛夫乔伊称两足行走为笨拙，原因与生物力学有关。两足奔跑消耗的能量是四足奔跑的两倍。也就是说，当我和我的狗跑步时，他消耗的能量是我的一半。
So Lovejoy and many other anthropologists think it's crazy to assume that the survival strategy of the early hominids involved running after quadrupeds. They've just got us beat, both in terms of speed and efficiency. But the thing is, if my dog and I go running in the summer in the middle of the day, when temperatures hit 85 to 100 or more degrees, it's a whole different ball game. He'll come with me and run for a while, but then he walks and lags behind. And sometimes, he just goes home. So if I'm an awkward and clumsy biped, why can I outrun my dog?
所以洛夫乔伊和许多其他人类学家认为，假设早期人类的生存策略包括追逐四足动物是疯狂的。它们在速度和效率方面都胜过我们。但问题是，如果我和我的狗在夏天中午跑步，当温度达到85到100华氏度或更高时，情况就完全不同了。他会跟我一起跑一会儿，但随后他会走起来并落在后面。有时，他干脆回家了。那么如果我是一个笨拙的二足动物，为什么我能跑过我的狗？
Well, it's because he overheats. The main way that he and most other quadrupeds cool themselves when they run is by breathing. The air coming in and going out of their mouth evaporates water off of their tongues. We do this too, but we do it all over our body by sweating. And then we get a nice flow of air directly over our skin because we don't have a fur coat. So we can't run as fast as a quadruped, but we can run farther, especially in high heat.
嗯，这是因为他过热了。他和大多数其他四足动物在奔跑时降温的主要方式是通过呼吸。空气进出口腔，使舌头上的水分蒸发。我们也这样做，但我们通过出汗在全身进行散热。而且因为我们没有皮毛大衣，所以气流可以直接吹在我们的皮肤上。所以我们跑得不如四足动物快，但我们可以跑得更远，特别是在高温下。
And when you remember that we're using twice the energy, this seems like a very strange biological paradox. And it was this paradox, combined with the argument about not being able to hunt without tools, that made my brother and I decide it was time to try to run down an antelope.
当你记住我们消耗的能量是两倍时，这看起来似乎是一个非常奇怪的生物学悖论。正是这个悖论，加上关于没有工具就无法狩猎的争论，使我兄弟和我决定是时候尝试追赶一只羚羊了。
Antilocapra americana. The pronghorn. The second-fastest land mammal on the planet. We thought that if we could keep one running for two hours on a hot day, we'd have it beat.
叉角羚。地球上第二快的陆地哺乳动物。我们认为如果我们能让它在一个炎热的日子里跑两个小时，我们就能胜过它。
[MEN RUNNING AND PANTING]
[男人们奔跑和喘息的声音]
What happened?
怎么了？
They didn't even give me a chance. I was able to follow them for about 30 minutes, but the problem was I wasn't sure if I was following the same ones I started following, because I started out following four-- a buck, two does, and a younger one. And after about 10 minutes, they ran into a group of about five more antelope, went over a hill, and then on the other side of the hill, they broke into two groups again.
它们甚至没给我机会。我能跟随它们大约30分钟，但问题是我不确定我是不是在跟随我开始跟随的那几只，因为我开始追赶四只——一只公的，两只母的，还有一只较小的。大约10分钟后，它们跑进了一群大约五只其他的羚羊中，翻过了一座小山，然后在小山的那一边，它们又分成了两组。
So I think I ended up following the same four, but I couldn't be sure. And I followed them for another 15 minutes, and then they ran into a much larger group, ran for a ways, and then followed that larger group for a while, And then that group broke into at least two more groups. And at that point, I just sort of gave up and quit following them because I didn't know which individuals I was chasing. And then I got confused on the roads. Where's the road we were on? Down here?
所以我认为我最终跟随的是同样的那四只，但我无法确定。我又跟了它们15分钟，然后它们碰到了一大群，跑了一段距离，然后又跟着那群大的一会儿，然后那群又分成了至少两组。在那个时候，我就放弃了，停止跟随它们，因为我不知道我在追哪几只。然后我在路上迷路了。我们刚才在的那条路在哪？在这儿下面吗？
Yeah.
是的。
OK, what happened was I came out on this road, way over there somewhere. And I got lost. I didn't know really where I was. I felt like that road-- I was walking along that road for about 15 minutes. I felt like that was the wrong direction. So we started over there.
好的，发生的情况是我来到了这条路上，在远处的某个地方。我迷路了。我真的不知道我在哪儿。我觉得那条路——我沿着那条路走了大约15分钟。我觉得那方向不对。所以我们从那边开始的。
Yeah.
是的。
Well, they ran in a circle, then. Because we went off-- I don't remember crossing this road, but I must've originally, early on.
好吧，那它们就绕圈跑了。因为我们离开了——我不记得穿过这条路，但我最初肯定穿过，很早就穿过了。
This one?
这条路？
Yeah. They ran in a circle. They came back. Well, strike one.
是的。它们绕圈跑了。它们回来了。好吧，出局一次。
What do you think we should do?
你觉得我们该怎么办？
I think we should go look for some more.
我觉得我们应该去找更多。
Not keep doing these?
不再做这些了？
Well, I don't know where they are. I think the main group went off in that direction. They may have circled back around to where they were originally, in that area.
嗯，我不知道它们在哪。我觉得那一群主要向那个方向去了。它们可能已经绕回了它们最初所在的区域。
It could have been the Serengeti-- orange and green and purple plains, a hot sun, thin, high clouds, blue mountains on the horizon.
那本可能是塞伦盖蒂——橙色、绿色和紫色的平原，炽热的太阳，薄薄的、高悬的云彩，地平线上蓝色的山脉。
They just zoomed. And they weren't stopping.
它们只是飞速驰骋。而且它们没有停下来。
It could've been the Serengeti, but we were no primitive hunters. We quickly realized we knew nothing about the animal we were chasing or the land we were running on. We ran after several herds that first day without much success.
那可能是塞伦盖蒂，但我们根本不是原始猎人。我们很快意识到，对于我们追赶的动物或我们奔跑的土地，我们一无所知。第一天我们追了好几个兽群，都没什么成功。
That night, sleeping out, I remember feeling very high in terms of elevation, like being dizzy. There weren't any clouds in the sky, and it just seemed like too much open space. Satellites in orbit, the moon in orbit, and antelope in the bushes, chewing their cuds, and laughing amongst themselves.
那天晚上露宿时，我记得感觉海拔很高，就像头晕一样。天空中没有一丝云彩，空间开阔得太过分了。卫星在轨道上，月亮在轨道上，灌木丛里的羚羊在反刍，在它们之间嬉笑。
The next morning, we had a breakfast of chocolate chip cookies and orange juice and walked around waiting for the air to heat up.
第二天早上，我们的早餐是巧克力豆曲奇和橙汁，走来走去等着空气变热。
What is it?
那是什么？
It's a white-tailed jackrabbit.
是白尾杰克兔。
We found dead animals, bare bones, an abandoned house.
我们发现了死去的动物、裸露的骨头、一栋废弃的房子。
You think someone used to live here?
你觉得以前有人住在这里吗？
We saw dust devils, horned toads, an eagle. We found a small lake, some badlands, and a rattlesnake.
我们看到了尘卷风、角蜥、一只老鹰。我们发现了一个小湖、一些荒地和一只响尾蛇。
[SOUND OF RATTLESNAKE RATTLING]
[响尾蛇的摇铃声]
Wow.
哇。
It never did get very hot that day, but in the afternoon, we had a good, long chase after a female and two males. They ran in circles around an area of about 10 square miles. There were two hills and a long, smooth valley in between, And the chase went up and around and back and forth between these hills, the antelope running short periods of time, but covering long distances, and then stopping and waiting for us to catch up. The two males ran behind the female, as if they were trying to protect her. And sometimes they'd all go in different directions. But we stayed behind the female, and the males would eventually rejoin her.
那天天气一直没怎么变热，但在下午，我们对一只雌性和两只雄性进行了长期的追赶。它们绕着大约10平方英里的区域绕圈。中间有两座小山和一条长而平坦的山谷，追逐在这些山丘之间进行，羚羊跑上一小段时间，但覆盖了很长的距离，然后停下来等着我们赶上。两只公的跑在雌的后面，好像它们在试图保护它。有时它们都会朝不同的方向跑。但我们一直跟在雌性后面，公的最终会重新加入它。
One thing we'd learned the day before was that we could run much less distance than the antelopes by staying well inside their circle. And we were also starting to communicate with each other over long distances. For instance, if my brother was on top of one of the hills and he could see where the antelope were going, he'd point, and I wouldn't have to run to the top of the hill.
我们前一天学到的一件事是，通过保持在它们圆圈的内部，我们可以比羚羊少跑很多距离。而且我们也开始在长距离沟通。例如，如果我兄弟在其中一座小山上，他能看到羚羊要去哪里，他会指点，我就不需要跑到山顶上。
So we were running after these three and feeling pretty good about not letting them ditch us. And a couple times, we even got within 50 yards of them. And I'd look into their eyes trying to see some sign of fear or fatigue. But all I kept seeing were very quiet animals that seemed to know exactly who we were, what we were proposing, and didn't seem to be in the least bit worried.
所以我们跑着追这三只，并且为没让它们甩掉我们而感觉很不错。有好几次，我们甚至进入了它们50码之内。我盯着它们的眼睛，试图看到一丝恐惧或疲劳的迹象。但我看到的只是非常安静的动物，它们似乎知道我们是谁，我们在提议什么，而且看起来一点也不担心。
Anyway, we ran after these three for about an hour, and then they found a large herd. Or the herd found them. And they ran up and over a hill. And by the time we got to the top of the hill, the herd had split into three groups of about three or four antelopes each. And each of the groups seemed to have at least one female that looked exactly like the one we'd started chasing. The magic shell game trick again. We weren't really all that physically tired, Mainly mentally beaten. And we went home.
总之，我们追了这三只大约一个小时，然后它们发现了一大群。或者那个群体发现了它们。它们跑上山又跑下来。当我们到达山顶时，那个群体已经分成了三组，每组大约三四只羚羊。每组中似乎都至少有一只雌性，看起来和我们刚开始追的那只一模一样。又是魔术壳牌游戏诡计。我们在身体上并没有那么疲惫，主要是精神上被打败了。然后我们回家了。
I haven't gone back to Wyoming for the purpose of chasing antelope, but I drive through there sometimes on my way somewhere else. And one time last spring, I was going east and there was a train along the highway also going east at about the same speed. And suddenly, there were three antelope running alongside the engine, chasing it.
我还没回过怀俄明州去追羚羊，但我有时会开车经过那里去其他地方。去年春天有一次，我正向东行驶，公路旁有一列火车也以同样的速度向东行驶。突然，有三只羚羊在引擎旁边奔跑，追赶着它。
It was incredible. It was even more incredible seeing the three of them simultaneously speed up, pull out in front of the engine, and fly across the tracks. I pulled over and waited for the train to go by. And there they were, three young males, looking back at me with those black eyes and hardly breathing at all.
太不可思议了。看到它们三只同时加速，跑到引擎前面，飞越铁轨，更加不可思议。我靠边停车，等着火车过去。它们就在那儿，三只年轻的公羚羊，用那些黑色的眼睛看着我，几乎没怎么喘气。
In the years since he first recorded that story, Scott has put it into a collection of his stories, a book called, simply, Running After Antelope.
在他第一次录下那个故事以来的几年里，斯科特把它收录进了一个故事集，书名很简单，叫《追赶羚羊》。
[MUSIC - "I WANNA BE LIKE YOU" BY DISNEY'S THE JUNGLE BOOK]
[音乐 - 迪士尼《森林王子》中的《我想成为你》]
The great Louis Prima from  the Jungle Book soundtrack. Our program was produced today by Peter Clowney and me with Alix Spiegel and Nancy Updike. Contributing editors for this show, Paul Tough, Jack Hitt, and Margy Rochlin. Original music for the opening story on today's program by Jeff Mueller and Jason Noble. Other musical help from Mr. John Connors and the mysterious Rumpety Rattles. You can download today's program and our archives at audible.com/thisamericanlife. This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International.
《森林王子》原声带中伟大的路易斯·普里马。我们今天的节目由彼得·克劳尼和我制作，艾莉克斯·斯皮格尔和南希·厄普代克参与制作。本节目的特约编辑为保罗·托夫、杰克·希特和玛吉·罗克林。今天节目开头故事的原创音乐由杰夫·穆勒和杰森·诺布尔创作。感谢约翰·康纳斯先生和神秘的隆佩蒂·响尾蛇提供的其他音乐帮助。您可以在audible.com/thisamericanlife下载今天的节目和我们的档案。《美国生活》由公共广播国际发行。
[FUNDING CREDITS]
[资金赞助信息]
WBEZ management oversight for our program by Mr. Torey Malatia, who treats his employees this way.
我们节目的WBEZ管理监督人为托里·马拉蒂亚先生，他对待员工的方式是这样的。
Must bite! Must bite! No, no, nice, nice. Bite! Must bite! Must bite!
必须咬！必须咬！不，不，乖，乖。咬！必须咬！必须咬！
I'm Ira Glass, back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯，下周带着更多《美国生活》的故事回来。
PRI, Public Radio International.
PRI，公共广播国际。